good evening we are one step closer to
getting the first
mega kobit 19 vaccination site up and
running in southern nevada
thanks for joining us here at six i'm
denise valdez
good evening everyone i'm brian loftis
today crews were hard at work
getting the system up and running at
cashman center before ultimately
allowing the public
to get the vaccine today we are getting
a look inside that site
joe mohler is going to take us inside he
did a tour earlier
with what you need to know hey joe
clark county is working hard to get this
vaccination site up and running today
was the trial day before they opened to
the public tomorrow now if you do have
an appointment you have to fill out
a very easy vaccination form you can
either get it here at the site or online
clark county officials hope to do at
least two thousand vaccines
a day as you can see we've been pretty
busy
clark county is just about ready to open
its first cove 19 mega vaccination site
the goal here is to get immunizations
out to the public
thursday was the trial run to identify
ways to improve the system
roughly one thousand critical workers
and those who will be working at this
site were vaccinated
the public will use the site starting
friday including people over the age of
70.
today is just closed groups that fall
within that tier one that we're able to
reach out to that actually had people
for us to test our system
appointments will be made online soon
the county expects to have this vaccine
administration record online as well
right now those getting the vaccine are
filling it out in person when they
arrive
it's a vaccination report and it just
states any of the contraindications that
you might be on there that you
understand
what you're doing after the county
announced the expansion of the
vaccination efforts this week the site
for appointments was down due to so many
people logging on
we hope by monday that we can work out
the
i.t issues so that they can start
registering
when the mega center is operating
smoothly they hope to vaccinate 4 000
people
a day the problem is getting through
there there's a lot of people some of
them may have been luck
vicky and ted mink spent hours trying to
make an appointment online wednesday
to be extra prepared they stopped by the
site to see where to go
we're really happy with being able to
get in the first day
now this vaccination site will be open
seven days a week now we know the
website is having issues but you are
encouraged to check back periodically
you just heard that couple spend several
hours
and they were able to get through and
make their appointment for next week
reporting live here at cashman center
joe mueller 8 news now